hey friends slightly different video
today it is a compilation of three wraps
the best bits from each wrap where
instead of rapping about words I was
rapping about objects and things that
people gave me from their pockets and
their bags based on a format made famous
by MC soup and that for one of the
original freestyle is if you want to
come see me do it live then I have tour
dates on sale click bet it will take you
and tell you everywhere that I am
performing also if you're not subscribed
please do subscribe makes me super happy
and King Canute it also very happy
enjoy the video fly rapper no bling on
the neck 47 86 yeah we're it on the
chick
Peyton mr. David Lily you might feel
silly if I tore it on stage oh I Billy
47 pounds in there 86 P manager suspense
one then three is the number branch sort
code and the count why is it for such a
specific amount of why hasn't it been
paid in row its from the 9th of October
two months ago
add another one then the check might
bounce yeah I don't give a [ __ ] with
little amount I need to get more money I
get the thrills here's a little packet
and just one pill remaining coming to
take two of them it does nothing when
it's just one year of n ibuprofen but
the brand name if you want the swelling
in your brain no pain
NSA ID that's the medical terminology
but only one person knew it this is a
tie clip it's got a mechanism in it if
it might slip does it work
no source of derision of your German
mechanical precision is important
they're not homemade Snoop Dogg dropping
down the retro shades
yeah that's an internet meme if you're
under 27 or a preteen you will get that
a shout and a holler this is worth more
than a pound it's a dollar isamazing
currently the currency it's got George
Washington on the front you can see you
can't spend it here I should take it
home but literally I'm okay got plenty
on my own this is really good the way I
rap I take your breath away need inhaler
ship for that
tap tap on your mouth it
in what brand is this it's the ventolin
I'll return this in case your lungs
collapse if you're going out barefaced
looking real crap
neither makeup brush applying the Rouge
we've got to change these doll the
bacteria broods and breeds and saddles
change it frequently I apply lipstick
with a line of frequency or what you
guys got present me with a card a key to
your hotel oh my god of Butlins who why
the [ __ ] would you go there see an old
guy red jacket no hair se-na is a joke i
learnt from me dad all the entertainment
in bollocks is so bad and lashing like
Abba tributes of Oasis it makes no sense
please don't stay this go to work for
air places like Brighton provisional
driving license ghetto right one what
the [ __ ] is up with you passing your
damn test mr. James
Antony Lancaster from the Lancashire is
that where you're from no you're from
home actually uh moving on are you
allowed to drive any trucks or HPVs
or a motorcycle no your license ain't
got the B letter on when did you get it
you're bought in 1992 that's [ __ ]
pathetic I could drive from 17 I'm three
years older need to get this in the
wallet in the holder you already broke
it's got a crack that's put in the
protractor a gift from a cracker you can
trace the shapes inside it's got a
question mark and a little plus sign the
position to the right the symbol for
addition if I wanna make sure I don't
have the missions that are filed from my
mouth I'll tell you bro I keep my breath
fresh when I pop a roll of polos any two
for one pound are RP take the foil off
the telescope I can see you can pull a
pencil through the empty space I like a
full Apollo mini in my face by the
inhaler I put it in I got no chin but I
pop been tooling and in my mouth clean
like a bar result looking like I got a
face with the periscope I never pop the
top of breath a button down if you have
a mad night out on the town if you're
going real hard drinking with your whole
team make sure you bring to match your
green routine yeah I brought my own tea
bugs
I don't need your lager I'm a big lad
give me just a glass of boiling water I
let's keep three minutes or maybe four
infuse for up to 15 the longest infusion
time I have ever seen
64 percent fair trade 18 fair wild wow
this T is hippier than a child called
Apple a reference from 15 years ago if
you've got your hair long and none show
who use a nice glass with the sparkly
crystals on the back looking nice and
amidst all the hair decorations that I
can't wear you've laid out such a
collection down there
verse 1 I hold it up when your
eyesight's beam you can see it's a kind
of Vaseline that's green that is the
aloe flavor a little tea light that you
want to stay there
wave it around or maybe to walk into a
church and put it at the tomb of someone
who deserves tip this life I returned it
yes to y'all
oh no he's gonna guess so wax lyrical
this is amazing you came back and I
really missed you bring it in the fifth
year I got an empty picture no liquid in
you downed it at all see you wanna have
tea wanna have a ball
it says Pilsner on the side i will
swatch your ping for mine whoa going in
angry like Jason Bourne I grow hard from
the ground like a [ __ ] acorn what a
weird shape why isn't it more oval I
want to grow be a tree be hopeful
looking like a little ottoman huh if you
want to grow a tree then I'm bringing it
back anything from you guys that you
wanna present it's a lipstick thing oh
how pleasant I try and see the color I
see it with my head made by Maybelline
it's probably [ __ ] red all that stick
is I know it sounds hurtful maybe you
like coral pinkish or purple it all look
the same to us oh well anyway we know
man
you can't tell and they don't give a
[ __ ] words might fail me why would you
put in a cracker a fingernail see it's
so small and green it looks odd what you
doing being in The Wizard of Oz at 31
you'll see why that's relevant a moment
I'll say it again you're 31 years old
but got a bingo pen what the [ __ ] why
have you got it with you there
you should only possess it if you've got
grey hair maybe your blue-rinse in the
bingo hall is so thick encase your
fingers fail got arthritis so you try
and tap it round let me give it back
the tip is so round I call it spherical
and now I might discuss a tangle teezer
my favorite type well brush it make sure
there's no nuts in my hair I can see
it's very straight very silky down there
anything from you guys here up say what
is it I thought it was a little bit of
makeup on a lipstick but no it's much
smaller in size there I put some
fragrance in my atomizer when I'm at
home I like to spray the Cologne return
that a fiddle while we burn Rome made a
little fan out there entry form I can
make sure I've got a draft if I get warm
looking like a lady from feudal Japan
return that if I'm an asthmatic man I'll
take breath away with a little bit of
tap ventolin in case you have an attack
I'll give it back here we go
it's so strange the range of the flavors
in this orange Terry's chocolate I just
can't wait it's very cool if you tap it
open like a slate I've go straight over
here I say again a little bag brought
straight from H&M a nice guy pink shirt
with a bowtie
let me hold up your shopping so high
what the [ __ ] inside it makes my knees
weak it looks like you murdered and
brought along a sheep stick
fool they're full of wool in the back I
give it back here such a nice day pal an
hour para panties our little pair of
knickers who was the size on the back is
it kind of bigger than anything I've
seen yes it really is and he could fit
me I'm my name is Chris I like it though
yeah the nice black and lacy ladies
taking knickers off and going crazy
wanted me to throw it at home you be
putting underwear like my name's Tom
Jones two for one entry and I went there
Shrek's adventure and the Sea Life
Centre jet in the world
maybe Alton Towers saving all the money
is in everybody's power using by the
30th the March next year
otherwise they reject it right there did
you get off a pack of cereal give it
over there yeah come nearer y'all okay
ball doesn't go long enough lately Marc
Jacobs that's the fragrance Daisy I knew
that from the shape of the bowl and
manage that [ __ ] like my name's Glenn
Hoddle give it back Jer I'm going full
troll you almost dropped that but my
grip is a lot Oh oh man that is bad luck
fella on the stage we'd be holding up
umbrellas you Mendeleev the moisture
outside shake it when you go there and
don't provide HSBC UK we can all see the
quality of this means that it was free
all unity from a bank
you saw it door and zort yeah I'll take
it walk out the door it's amazing a hip
pop like pop and locking make it come
back [ __ ] like Mary Poppins there you go
thank you so much for watching there a
playlist here you can check
more of my video with my favorite
freestyle rap again if you haven't
subscribed please do like it leave a
comment share it around and come and see
me live I would love to see you at some
live show until next time bye bye